from the horrifying truth about how
Gilbert made his black flame candles to
hidden secrets about the witch mother
there are some outrageously plausible
Hocus Pocus 2 fan theories we need to
talk about yippikai movie lovers I'm Jan
and I've been reading all your comments
to find the very best theories about the
Hocus Pocus Sequel and what their ending
might really mean in Hocus Pocus 2
Gilbert's ultimately responsible for
bringing the Sanderson sisters back as
he secretly gives Becca a black flame
candle to light on her 16th birthday and
one of our amazing movie lovers that
monster life has a particularly gruesome
theory about how Gilbert made the candle
based on what we know from the first
movie about the grisly way those candles
are created black flame candle made from
the fat of a hangman now public hanging
stopped long before Gilbert's time but
was he so obsessed with the Sanderson
sisters that he killed someone to make
the black flame candle that would
reanimate them they were ahead of their
time and they were misunderstood in fact
it was book that taught in the shocking
method he needed to make the magic
Candle on the night the sisters died in
1993. he said we had to make another
candle I mean it wasn't pretty which
means when young Gilbert went to the
witch's Cottage he would have discovered
Jay and I still locked in their cages as
we saw in the original movie's
mid-credit scene those two bullies who
were literally hanging there could have
been the source for the fat of two
hanged men for the two black flame
candles we know Gilbert made terrible as
they were though that would be an
especially brutal form of Revenge for
stealing his Halloween candy so perhaps
Gilbert did his own horrifying DIY
version of liposuction on the bullies
instead the opening scene with the witch
mother and the young Sanderson sisters
added some intriguing mythology to the
Hocus Pocus lore it also opened up lots
of new questions such as what happened
to the witch mother's coven where is thy
coven long gone I'm afraid the world is
not too fond of witches at first sight
it seems like she lost her coven to
witch Hunters or trials however there
are some big clues that she could well
have lost them after casting the Magic
Eye Maxima spell herself which is why
she warned Winifred against using the
spell as fellow movie lover David points
out magikai Maxima makes a witch all
powerful it is most frowned upon doomed
is the witch that uses this spell and
that theory is supported by Wolfie girl
and ejam music's observation that the
witch mother's eyes glow purple when she
uses her powers similar to how Winnie's
eyes also go purple as she casts the
Magic Eye Maximus fell and takes on the
extra Powers all of which makes me
wonder if the witch Mother originally
casts the spell to increase her power in
order to protect herself and her coven
but inadvertently lost her sisters in
the process Thou Art lucky to have each
other a witch is nothing without her
coven Hocus Pocus 2 ends with Sarah and
Mary first Fading Into sparkly dust
Winnie joining them and as they merge
into a giant swirl of lights they
disappear with a sudden burst of energy
seemingly for good this time but another
of our marvelous movie lovers Stephanie
thinks that the very final scene of
Becca Izzy and Cassie doing the iconic
Sanderson witch walk might imply the
original sisters have now possessed the
bodies of the teenage girls and indeed
there is a nod towards this idea when
Cassie and backers say they don't
understand what's happening to them
I don't know this could suggest the
girls are under the control or influence
of some unknown force my feeling is this
probably isn't the actual Sanderson
sisters reincarnated but instead the
mischievous Spirit of the infamous Trio
has passed on to the new young witches
it might also have something to do with
the witch mother Raven which is flying
along and watching them in that final
shot after the young Sanderson sisters
received the book from the witch mother
the first spell they talk about
performing is one that turns apart
person into a cat that would be good to
do to John Pritchett there is a black
cat called cobweb in the sequel and
movie lover Sage for real points out
that although we know it isn't Thackery
Banks the fact that the witches think it
is I know this really the Zachary could
suggest they sensed a human spirit in
the cat which might be that of John
Pritchett the boy Reverend Trask tried
to force young Winnie to marry and it
wouldn't surprise me if young Winnie did
punish him especially given his mean
comments about her in front of the whole
village it's only she is so ugly and
unpleasant in the present day cobweb
also helps Becca and Izzy find book
after they escape from the basement
perhaps because if he is John Pritchett
he'd want revenge on Winnie and her
sisters for what they did to him and
that reminds me of how after Thackery
Binks was turned into a cat he helped
Max Allison and Danny defeat the witches
the main issue I can see with this
theory is that we never see cobweb
talking unlike Binks who could speak in
the first movie you can talk yeah no
kidding now get the spell book though of
course that could be addressed in a
second sequel except for the OG which is
a good deal of the original cast ones in
the sequel but it hasn't stopped fans
speculating about hidden references and
possibilities movie lover Jesse says
that Cassie's house looks exactly like
Alison's one from the first film and
Annie also adds that Alison is Cassie's
mother because according to the actress
who plays Cassie her cardigan is a
deliberate callback to Alison's look now
I've checked the houses from each film
and Cassie's home does have some similar
features to Allison's such as stairs
leading up to the front door each house
being five Windows wide and having
shutters however Cassie's house is
larger with three floors below the roof
rather than two and there's an
additional balcony above the main
entrance these differences could be
explained by assuming that since 1993
the house has been remodeled and
extended the main issue with this theory
is that mertras campaign poster has both
Cassie and a woman that I assume is her
mother in the picture this clearly isn't
the grown-up Vanessa Shaw who played
Alison so for the theory to work this
would have to be Cassie's stepmother say
of course the theory also means that
Alison and Max broke up sometime after
the end of the first movie regarding the
OG gang of Max Allison and Danny a lot
of our movie lovers including Veronica
and Falco have been speculating that
they could return for a potential third
movie perhaps lining up with the new
witch Trio against the mother witch who
would be the new villain which could be
an awful lot of fun additionally a
likely plot for a third movie would be a
prequel story involving the three young
Sanders and sisters as Batman's Alter
Ego points out Bette Midler has said
that she was pleased that in Hocus Pocus
2 the filmmakers decided to let Winnie
go at the end after she realized her
family was the most important thing to
her and Middler thinks that the three
sisters should be laid to rest now
rather than returning for another movie
Bruce Wayne goes on to say that a
prequel story could be very interesting
if it follows the young sisters after
they're exiled from Salem go to live in
The Forbidden Forest and show them
interacting with the mother witch and
their experiments with book I think that
sounds great the young actresses did a
good job and I'm sure fans would love to
see a lot more of Hannah waddingham's
mother witch and as we already know from
her work in the show Ted lasso
waddingham could also easily do a
musical number in the third movie as
another of our awesome movie lovers
Miranda points out they could even jump
into the present day for some of the
story by setting up a connection between
the young Sanderson sisters and
characters from the first or second
movies for example fellow movie lover
Roland suggests that they could have
Alison be a descendant of Winnie through
her relationship with Billy this overall
idea of Winnie being Alison's ancestor
could work though I don't think it would
be with Billy as he insisted in the
second movie that he only shared a
single kiss with Winifred by the way
Roland's theory about Winnie and Alison
being related would also fit with the
popular fan theory about Alison being a
secret witch so what do you think about
these Hocus Pocus 2 Series and what
would you like to see in a potential
third movie Next tap left to discover
all the Easter eggs and little details I
spotted in the sequel and if you enjoyed
this video do leave a thumbs up I really
appreciate it thanks for enjoying this
movie with me and hope you have a
marvelous movie loving week yippee Kai
movie lovers